Dericks with us in Houston Texas welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Derek all
certainly I'm gonna help the question I
have here is I own 24,000 plus on my car
right now paying for 80 a month for it
and the question I have to kind of clean
up stupid is I should double down on the
car payments and get it paid off quicker
or should I actually surrender the car
and and go give me something cash okay
no we never surrender a car because
they're going to sell the car and way
below wholesale and sue you for the
difference that's called a repossession
so we don't want to do that one but what
is your household income 40,000 you're
single I know that Mary but stay an old
wife okay all right and one car there's
one car you owe 24,000 on do you have a
second car no no no I actually got rid
of my second car beforehand I doz it was
basically it cost me like 600 a month it
was like the most expensive car that we
had so I was like nah we gotta get rid
of this thing so we sold that one and
and gave them the payment for that and I
would double checking to see if I should
do the same with this one yeah if you
sell it that's fine surrendering it I
would not do now what is the car worth
do you have any idea don't have any idea
what the car is worth but I'm pretty
sure it might be around like the 10,000
area then you owe 2400 24 how do you owe
14 more on it is worth your own negative
equity from the other car into it equity
from a previous vehicle not the other
car that I that's what I mean but that
when you did a trade in you had negative
on the trade-in that's right and they
put it on this and then they jacked your
interest rate and smacked you in the
face no one else fine that's why I'm
trying to clean up stupid yeah
Wow is this your only death no no no I
still have my student loans that I have
and then I have some outstanding credit
card out of the collection like I
literally started watching yours your
programming about maybe like a month or
so ago yeah decision start taking things
don't you how old are you I'm 32 okay
yeah you got a mess um what we we look
at on how quickly someone can turn their
mess around is what we call what I call
the shovel to hole ratio the hole we're
in is the pile of debt the shovel is
your income and so it sounds like you
have a lot of debt compared to your
income agreed yeah I don't think you
want to turn this car in but I do I do
think we need to get it paid down as
rapidly as possible paid off so let's
try again 24 on the car how much is owed
on the student loans 25 and how much on
the credit card everything being right
71,000 gotcha okay alright and so what
we've got to do you know do you have
anything else you can sell I don't have
anything really hell okay how many kids
do you have well if you pay off $10,000
a year it takes you seven years you see
how I did that
yeah if you pay off $20,000 a year
$25,000 a year it takes you three years
25 $24,000 is $2,000 a month which means
you would need to increase your income
with an extra job during that three
years that paid pretty well delivering
pizzas mowing grass I don't care what it
is but you need to get and
extra $1,500 a month coming into your
house that and another 500 out of your
budget goes towards these debts and your
debt free in three years selling the car
doesn't help if it only brings ten of
the seventy and ten of the twenty-four
mm-hmm
you follow me if it would bring a lot
more than ten I'd sell it in a heartbeat
so I want you to look up on Kelly Blue
Book kbb.com and see what it's worth the
number one number two you're gonna be
working an extra job that pays well and
you're gonna be working a lot because
you got clean this mess up number three
you guys are gonna get on a written
budget that's scorched earth meaning you
have no life you're not eating out
you're not going on vacation you don't
see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're working there you have a mess to
clean up sir and it's going to require a
level of intensity a level of healthy
righteous anger at the mess to get the
mess cleaned up you can wander into this
kind of debt you cannot wander out you
got to get mad and go to war you
following what I'm saying and about a
month ago when I watched you the first
time which is why I'm in contact with
you right now
awesome so I want you to go through
Financial Peace University our nine week
class I'm gonna give it to you for free
because I've been where you are broken
scared and didn't know what to do but
I'm going to show you how to get out if
you'll go to that class I'll give it to
you okay yes and that includes the
one-year membership to the online
everything so you can do your every
dollar plus budget you and your spouse
do not miss a class and then stay with
the online budget stay back over the
lessons during the year
take the other classes in the online
during the year but go to the class the
Financial Peace University class for the
nine weeks and then financial peace the
membership goes with it I'm going to
throw all of that in together and I want
you to take it I want you to take care
of your family and turn this around and
you be the guy that changed your family
tree you're the last broke guy in your
family you change this Nick you can do
it and I'll help you if you get scared
or you don't know what to do while
you're walking through this it's going
to
three years you Amir together brother
and then from then on we're going to be
together because I'm gonna help you be
an everyday millionaire but you call me
if I can help you and you hold on
Kelly's gonna pick up and we'll get you
started